>> PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
I THINK Y'ALL GONNA HAVE
TO DO THE SHOOT IN AFRICA!
>> (screaming)
>> THE COMPETITION
MOVED FROM L.A.
TO CAPE TOWN, SOUTH AFRICA.
AT THE PHOTO SHOOT,
CHRISTINA TRIED TO WARM UP
HER CHILLY PERSONALITY...
>> IF WE COULD JUST HAVE
A LITTLE MORE WARMTH
IN THE FACE.
>> WHILE THE COMPETITION
WEIGHED HEAVILY ON KEENYAH.
>> WHEN I'M UNDER
A LOT OF STRESS,
I FIND A REAL COMFORT IN EATING.
I GAINED 12 POUNDS.
>> BUT IN THE END,
IT WAS MICHELLE WHO
COULDN'T TAKE THE PRESSURE.
>> MICHELLE,
YOU LOOK QUITE SCARED
THE WHOLE TIME.
>> AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
FIVE GIRLS REMAIN--
KEENYAH, BRITTANY,
CHRISTINA, NAIMA AND KAHLEN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
>> (singing in African language)
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE WE'RE IN
SOUTH AFRICA.
IT'S SO WEIRD TO ME.
>> I GET SO STRESSED OUT
SOMETIMES
THROUGHOUT THE COMPETITION,
BUT RIGHT NOW I JUST FEEL
REALLY, REALLY HAPPY.
>> MM-HMM.
WE'RE THE LAST FIVE.
I JUST FEEL GOOD ABOUT THAT.
>> HELLO!
>> TYRA'S HERE.
>> I BRING FOOD!
>> AAH!
>> AFRICAN FOOD.
>> KAHLEN.
>> I'LL WAKE HER UP.
UP.
>> (screaming)
>> DID YOU SEE HER?
>> DID YOU SEE HER EYES?
>> HOW ARE YOU GUYS FEELING,
LIKE, BEING THE LAST?
>> LAST WEEK WAS MY FIRST TIME
BEING ONE OF THE LAST TWO.
>> WILL KEENYAH AND MICHELLE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
>> TYRA TELLS ME,
"YOU KNOW WHAT?
THIS PICTURE IS BEAUTIFUL,
BUT WE HAD TO RETOUCH THE HECK
OUT OF YOUR STOMACH
JUST TO MAKE IT SLIM."
WOW!
THAT WAS, LIKE,
A BIG WAKE-UP CALL.
>> KEENYAH, I'VE STRUGGLED
THROUGH THE SAME THING.
I THINK IT'S ALL ABOUT CHOICES.
YOU CAN GET A BURGER
AND TAKE THE BREAD OFF.
>> I'M BRINGING IT.
I'M HITTIN' IT HARD NOW,
YOU KNOW?
>> DO YOU FEEL LIKE A DIFFERENT
PERSON SINCE
YOU'VE STARTED THIS COMPETITION?
>> I FEEL LIKE A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT PERSON.
IT'S BEEN QUITE A JOURNEY.
I WAS VERY ANGRY GROWING UP.
MY PARENTS DIVORCED,
SO I TOTALLY GOT
INTO THE PARTY SCENE
FOR A LONG TIME,
AND JUST, LIKE, GOING CRAZY
AND GETTING DRUNK
AND FEELING REALLY LOST.
>> I FEEL LIKE
I SEE SOMETHING THAT'S
MUFFLING ALL THE REAL STUFF
BEHIND YOU, AND I THINK IT'S,
UM, STIFLING YOUR PERSONALITY.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT?
LIKE, SOMETIMES WHEN WE TRY
TO FORGET EVERY SINGLE THING
THAT WE HAVE GONE THROUGH,
WE BECOME A LITTLE BIT MORE
OF A SHELL OF A PERSON.
>> I THINK I HAVE A TENDENCY
TO BE VERY SOFT-SPOKEN,
VERY MEEK SOMETIMES,
BECAUSE OF FEAR OF, LIKE,
RELIVING A PAST THAT I REALLY
WASN'T TOO COMFORTABLE WITH.
>> I FEEL SO LUCKY
BECAUSE THIS IS A COMPETITION,
AND I WANT TO KICK ALL OF
Y'ALLS BUTT,
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF YOU.
NO. BUT I'M SO HAPPY THAT
WE CAN GET ALONG SO WE DON'T
HAVE THAT, YOU KNOW,
JUST SOME GIRL JUST CONNIVING
AND JUST TRYING TO MESS YOU UP.
WE ACTUALLY ARE FRIENDS.
>> I THINK I FEEL LIKE
I'VE LEARNED SO MUCH
FROM THE OTHER GIRLS,
AND THEY'RE SUCH
STRONG PERSONALITIES,
AND IT MAKES YOU, YOU KNOW,
REALLY THINK, LIKE, WHO AM I?
LIKE, I'M ON THAT ROAD
TO FIGURING OUT WHO I AM.
OH, MY GOD!
>> ARE YOU CRYING?
>> NO.
>> IT'S OKAY.
>> I FEEL LIKE I HAVE GROWN
IN MANY WAYS JUST BECAUSE
I HAVE LET MYSELF
BE OPEN TO, YOU KNOW, YOU GUYS,
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO
KEEP BEING PORTRAYED AS, LIKE,
THE RESERVED GIRL,
THE COLD GIRL.
MY MOM'S ALWAYS TAUGHT ME ALWAYS
TO BE STRONG AND CONFIDENT,
AND IT COMES ACROSS AS, LIKE,
STERN OR COLD
TOWARDS THE JUDGES, AND IT
DOESN'T SHOW THE WARM SIDE OF ME
THAT I REALLY AM.
I FEEL LIKE FOR SOME REASON,
I HOLD BACK
WHEN IT COMES TO PANEL.
>> YOU HAVE TO JUST PRETEND
WE'RE SITTING THERE
IN OUR UNDERWEAR.
>> RIGHT, YOU IN YOUR UNDERWEAR
IS GONNA BE BEAUTIFUL,
SO THAT'S NOT GONNA HELP.
>> I'M GONNA BE
MORE INTIMIDATED.
>> I'LL BE LIKE,
"OH, LOOK AT HER BODY!"
>> NIGHT, GUYS. GIVE ME A HUG.
>> NIGHT, TYRA.
>> THANK YOU.
>> BYE!
>> BYE.
(laughter)
>> LET'S FINISH EATING DINNER.
>> I THINK I WANT
A LITTLE BIT MORE DINNER.
I'M LIKE, YOU KNOW WHAT?
THIS FOOD IS REALLY GOOD.
TURN AROUND,
MAKE SURE TYRA IS GONE,
I GO GET A LITTLE BIT MORE.
>> KEENYAH ALMOST GOT
ELIMINATED FOR BEING
A LITTLE HEAVYSET.
>> WHAT IF SHE CAME BACK?
AND OH!
>> GOT YOU!
>> YEAH?
LOCK THAT DOOR, PLEASE.
>> SHE TOOK IT VERY HARD,
BUT I REALLY DON'T FEEL THAT
SHE'S MADE THAT MUCH IMPROVEMENT
ON HER CHOICES.
>> IT WAS VERY GOOD.
>> IT WAS ALL GOOD.
♪♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
THAT WAS SLICK.
>> "STEP OUT ON THE CAPE TOWN
AND BE SEEN.
SHOW 'EM WHAT
YOU WORKIN' WITH."
>> MM.
>> "SHOW 'EM
WHAT YOU WORKIN' WITH."
>> HMM.
♪♪♪
>> HI, I'M JACKIE BURGER.
I'M THE FASHION DIRECTOR
AT "ELLE" MAGAZINE
IN SOUTH AFRICA.
>> MY NAME IS PAOLA DEVITO.
I AM THE C.E.O.
OF THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF MODELING AGENCIES.
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO TEACH YOU
ABOUT GO-SEES.
NOW A GO-SEE IS HOW YOU MEET
THE CLIENTS.
>> I THINK IT'S ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT INTERACTIONS
THAT YOU'LL EVER EXPERIENCE
IN YOUR CAREER.
>> YOU'RE A PRODUCT,
AND YOU'RE GOING OUT THERE
AND YOU'RE SELLING YOURSELF.
YOUR CHALLENGE FOR TODAY
IS TO GO ON GO-SEES, OKAY?
YOU'VE GOT, I THINK,
JUST OVER TEN PEOPLE TO SEE.
YOU'LL BE JUDGED ON
IF YOU GET TO THE GO-SEES,
PERSONALITY,
YOUR PORTFOLIO, YOUR LOOK
AND, UM, PROFESSIONALISM.
THAT'S YOUR PORTFOLIO.
THAT'S YOUR GO-SEE LIST.
YOU CAN GO TO ALL OF THEM.
YOU CAN GO TO NONE OF THEM.
YOU CAN DO WHATEVER YOU LIKE.
REMEMBER, IT'S A COMPETITION.
YOU HAVE TO BE BACK HERE
AT 4:30.
THAT'S THE ONLY THING
YOU HAVE TO DO.
OKAY, THERE IS A TAXI
WAITING FOR EACH OF YOU
DOWNSTAIRS.
>> PHOTOGRAPHERS, AGENTS,
DESIGNERS.
I MEAN, YOU NAME 'EM,
WE CAN GO SEE THEM.
SO GET ME DOWN TO MY CAB,
AND LET'S GO.
♪♪♪
>> CAN I GO TO
THE VICTORIA JUNCTION, GATE 4?
>> UM, NUMBER 131, SIR.
>> IT'S NERVE-RACKING BECAUSE
YOU'VE GOTTA RACE AGAINST TIME,
AND YOU WANNA TRY AND SEE
AS MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE.
>> WE'RE GOING TO, UM,
1012 JARVIS STREET.
I WANT TO WIN THIS COMPETITION,
AND RIGHT NOW
I'M IN THE POSITION OF,
OKAY, NAIMA, YOU HAVE TO
SHOW YOUR PERSONALITY
OR GO HOME.
♪♪♪
>> IS IT CLOSE?
>> I FEEL LIKE I NEED TO WIN
A CHALLENGE, AND THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT CHALLENGE.
GO-SEES ARE THE KEY
OF A MODEL'S CAREER.
>> HI. CHARLENE. YOU ARE...
>> I'M KEENYAH.
>> HI, KEENYAH.
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY STUNNING.
YOU DEFINITELY HAVE POTENTIAL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> HOW FAR AWAY ARE THESE, UM,
WITHIN DISTANCE FROM EACH OTHER?
>> 2, 3 KILOMETERS.
>> I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS
TO GO IN THERE
AND HAVE TO SELL YOURSELF,
AND THAT'S ONE THING I'M
HONESTLY NOT REALLY GOOD AT.
I LIKE THIS.
I FEEL LIKE
I'M NOT WEARING ANYTHING.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
I FEEL LIKE I'M IN MY PAJAMAS.
>> DO YOU?
>> I ALWAYS HAVE BEEN CONFIDENT.
I'VE ALWAYS CARRIED MYSELF WELL,
AND PEOPLE MISPERCEIVE THAT
AS COLD.
>> THAT'S IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
(beeping)
>> NO!
THIS IS RETARDED.
>> HOW LONG DO YOU HAVE TO
COMPLETE THIS WHOLE THING?
>> BY 4:30.
>> I JUST WALK INTO THESE
CHALLENGES WITH DETERMINATION
AND SHOW THAT I HAVE
SOMETHING BEAUTIFUL
AND INDIVIDUAL
TO OFFER THIS INDUSTRY.
>> IT'S NICE,
BUT YOUR FACE IS QUITE UNIQUE.
I LIKE THAT. I LIKE YOUR HAIR.
>> "PUSH TO CALL."
THAT'S WHAT I DID.
I'M HAVING A REALLY HARD TIME.
I JUST DID THIS.
I'M GETTING A LITTLE FRUSTRATED.
YEAH, WE GOT THAT.
(beep)
>> HERE WE ARE.
>> GREAT.
I THINK THAT
I WILL DO PRETTY GOOD
IN THIS CHALLENGE.
I'M REALLY GOOD WITH PEOPLE
AND I'M GONNA, LIKE, WALK IN
AND BE PROFESSIONAL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I THINK IT LOOKS LOVELY.
>> YEAH?
>> VERY NICE.
♪♪♪
(door buzzes)
>> YES!
>> CAN I SEE YOUR BOOK?
TAKE A SEAT.
>> I'VE NEVER BEEN ON A GO-SEE,
AND I KNOW THAT I AM A LITTLE
SHY AT TIMES
WHEN I FIRST MEET PEOPLE.
AS THIS COMPETITION PROGRESSES,
I REALIZE THAT YOU CAN'T
BE LIKE THAT.
>> NO. MNH-MNH.
>> OKAY.
>> I MEAN YES. (laughs)
>> MAYS CLOTHING,
16 NEWMARKET STREET.
16 NEWMARK STREET.
♪♪♪
>> I PULL UP,
AND NAIMA IS, LIKE, GETTING
OUT OF THE CAR.
I'M LIKE, NO, NO.
I HAVE TO GO, BECAUSE I AM NOT
WAITING FOR NAIMA TO BE DONE.
♪♪♪
>> WHEN WE GET TO THE STAIRS,
NAIMA IS STARTING TO
PUT ON A LITTLE JOG.
I'M, LIKE, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M IN FLATS.
I'M ABOUT TO WORK THIS OUT.
♪♪♪
>> SOME PEOPLE MAY THINK
NAIMA WAS THERE FIRST,
I CAME SECOND,
MAYBE I SHOULD JUST WAIT.
BUT IT'S A COMPETITION.
HI, I'M KEENYAH.
>> AND I'M LIKE,
"FORGET THAT, KEENYAH.
YOU ARE NOT TAKING THIS
FROM ME."
>> (laughing)
♪♪♪
>> TODAY'S CHALLENGE IS
BASICALLY US HAVING
A LIST OF 12 GO-SEES TO GO TO
AND BE BACK BY 4:30.
>> I ARRIVED BEFORE HER,
BUT ONCE WE GET INTO
CRAIG PORT'S OFFICE,
SHE JUST KIND OF SAYS,
"HI, I'M KEENYAH,"
AND BOGARTS ME OUT THE WAY.
>> OKAY.
>> KEENYAH DOES HAVE
THIS PROBLEM WITH GAINING
A LOT OF WEIGHT.
I'M NOT SURE HOW SHE'S
GONNA FEEL ABOUT
ABOUT TRYING ON HIS CLOTHING.
>> I'M LIKE,
"OH, GOD, PLEASE LET THIS FIT!"
(drumroll playing)
>> YES, THANK YOU, GOD.
AND I THINK I DID PRETTY GOOD.
I HAD MY EYE ON THE PRIZE,
AND I REALLY DON'T CARE
WHAT IT TAKES TO GET THERE.
>> SHE LEAVES,
AND I REALIZE AT THAT POINT
THAT I NEED TO WORK
AS HARD AS I CAN IN ORDER TO WIN
THIS COMPETITION.
HI. HOW ARE YOU?
>> HI. HOW ARE YOU?
>> I'M NAIMA.
>> VERY GOOD.
YOU HAVE A GREAT WALK.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I'M LIKE, "ALL RIGHT.
I'M GONNA WIN THIS."
JUST AS LONG AS WE MAKE
ALL OF THEM TODAY.
>> OKAY, THAT'S IMPORTANT.
>> OKAY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> HOW OLD ARE YOU?
>> I'M 22.
>> OH, WELL, BRILLIANT.
YOU'RE CONFIDENT, YOU'RE STRONG,
YOU KNOW WHERE YOU ARE.
>> I HAVE BEEN THROUGH
THE ENTIRE YOUNG,
JUST WANT TO HAVE FUN
AND PARTY STAGE OF MY LIFE.
>> I HAVE STAIRS LIKE THIS
IN MY APARTMENT, SO...
OH! BUT I DON'T HAVE--
>> OH, REALLY?
>> YEAH, HIP-HOP, GREAT.
>> AH. BEAT HER.
>> HERE WE ARE.
>> WE GOT GATES EVERYWHERE.
OH, I'LL JUST PUSH.
NO.
I STARE AT HER, AND I'M LIKE,
"SHE'S GONNA TRY
AND JUMP IN FRONT OF ME."
>> KEENYAH.
>> MOVE. IT PULLS BACK.
IT PULLS BACK.
>> I FEEL IT IS KIND OF RUDE.
YOU KNOW, IF KEENYAH WOULD'VE
GOT THERE BEFORE ME,
I WOULD'VE, YOU KNOW,
RESPECTED THAT AND, YOU KNOW,
LET HER GO FIRST.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DON'T HAVE TIME FOR THIS.
DANG IT, KEENYAH.
OKAY, I'M NOT HIP-HOP ANYWAYS.
I'M NOT SURPRISED
BY KEENYAH'S BEHAVIOR.
KEENYAH IS VERY COMPETITIVE.
THAT'S JUST HOW SHE IS.
AND I THINK THAT AFTER
THE LAST ELIMINATION,
SHE FEELS THAT SHE HAS TO
STEP IT UP EVEN MORE
TO MAKE UP FOR HER WEIGHT.
>> HI.
>> OKAY, I GOTTA CUT THIS ONE
REALLY, REALLY CLOSE.
WE HAD, YOU KNOW,
15 MINUTES LEFT TO GET
BACK TO THE HOTEL IN TIME,
BUT I WANTED TO GO
TO ONE LAST PLACE.
HI, ARE YOU CHRISTIAAN?
>> HI. NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> CHRISTINA.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> HELLO, HELLO.
>> SORRY IF I FEEL RUSHED. I
HAVE FIVE MINUTES BEFORE
I HAVE TO BE BACK TO THE HOTEL--
>> SO IT'S ALWAYS VERY IMPORTANT
TO HAVE THE MODEL UNDERSTANDING
WHAT THE GARMENT STANDS FOR...
>> I WAS THINKING, "I HAVE TO BE
BACK"
INSTEAD OF WONDERING ABOUT
EVERYTHING I SHOULD'VE BEEN
FOCUSED ON THERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD LUCK WITH EVERYTHING.
>> FANTASTIC. GOOD LUCK. AND
YOU, TOO.
>> OH. HOW FAR ARE WE AWAY?
>> IT'S ALMOST 4:30 NOW.
>> OKAY. LET'S JUST GO BACK.
>> WE HAVE TO BE BACK BY 4:30,
AND IT HAS BEEN MADE VERY CLEAR
BY PAOLA.
>> I REALLY HAVE TO GET BACK
TO THE HOTEL RIGHT NOW.
RIGHT NOW!
>> OKAY.
I HAVE THE CHOICE TO EITHER HEAD
BACK TO THE HOTEL
OR TRY AND SQUEEZE IN
A COUPLE MORE GO-SEES.
>> ARE WE GONNA MAKE IT?
>> OH.
>> ARE WE VERY FAR AWAY, SIR?
>> WE'LL STOP HERE.
>> YES.
>> THE MORE GO-SEES YOU GO ON,
THE MORE PEOPLE SEE YOU,
AND YOU NEVER KNOW WHO'S
GONNA GIVE YOU THAT BREAK.
>> YEAH.
>> HELLO, LADIES.
>> HI.
>> THANK YOU.
>> HELLO.
>> OKAY.
>> I GET BACK,
AND THERE IS NO NAIMA.
>> OKAY.
NO ANSWER.
>> WE TRIED.
>> YEAH.
>> THANK YOU, ANYWAYS.
>> DO YOU THINK YOU CAN COME
AFTER WORK TOMORROW?
>> WE'RE ALL JUST KINDA SITTING
THERE,
STARING INTO SPACE, AND WE'RE
ALL WONDERING WHERE NAIMA IS.
>> 45 MINUTES LATE.
YOU WANT TO TELL ME WHY?
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS
VERY IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE
I TRIED TO SEE EVERYONE.
>> NAIMA PRETTY MUCH KNEW
WHAT SHE WAS DOING.
SHE PROBABLY THINKS THAT SHE'S
GONNA BEAT US ALL BECAUSE
SHE WENT TO MORE GO-SEES.
>> YOU REALLY DON'T KNOW WHAT
WAS HAPPENING HERE AT 4:30.
>> I'M FEELING LIKE I'M NOT
GOING TO WIN THIS CHALLENGE
BECAUSE I REALLY
MESSED THIS ONE UP.
>> SO DON'T DO THAT.
OKAY, LADIES,
I GOT YOUR SCORE SHEETS.
I'M GONNA JUST RUN THROUGH THEM
AND GIVE YOU SOME OF
THE COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE.
CAROLINE AT INFIDELS,
BRITTANY--BUBBLY PERSONALITY.
THAT'S A LOVELY COMMENT
TO MAKE.
AND, NAIMA--GREAT FACE,
LOVE THE WAY YOU PHOTOGRAPH.
AND THEN GAVIN RAJAH--
KEENYAH--GORGEOUS, COULD BE
A LITTLE BIT MORE GRACEFUL,
AND THE COMMENT FOR YOU
WAS TOO INNOCENT.
>> HEARING THAT
I'M NOT EDGY ENOUGH
IS A LITTLE DISCOURAGING,
BECAUSE HERE IN SOUTH AFRICA,
THIS IS WHERE A LOT
OF THE NEW FACES, YOU KNOW,
ARE BREAKING.
>> UH, CHRISTIAAN GABREIL--
FOR CHRISTINA--
SHE LOOKED BORED.
>> I WASN'T BORED,
BUT I WAS THINKING,
"I HAVE TO BE BACK."
YOU KNOW, I DEFINITELY
HAVE LEARNED, IF YOU DON'T THINK
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE ENOUGH TIME
TO ACTUALLY GIVE ALL OF
YOURSELF, THEN MAYBE NOT GO AT
ALL.
>> NOT ONLY WAS TODAY A TASK,
BUT IT WAS A COMPETITION,
AND TONIGHT'S PRIZE IS
YOU ARE GOING TO BE TAKEN
IN A LIMOUSINE
TO CRAIG PORT'S HOUSE
FOR DINNER.
♪♪♪
>> THE WINNER IS...
KEENYAH.
>> WOW!
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> KEENYAH WINNING
THIS COMPETITION ANNOYS ME
BECAUSE SHE DOESN'T THINK
ABOUT OTHER PEOPLE.
>> YOU'VE GOT FIVE SECONDS
TO PICK SOMEONE TO GO WITH YOU.
>> PICK ONE.
>> I'M SORRY. BRITTANY.
>> BRITTANY, YOU KNOW,
ANY SITUATION WE HAVE,
SHE'S GONNA BE FUN.
>> GOOD LUCK TO THE REST OF YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> OKAY. CIAO.
♪♪♪
>> I'M SO GLAD YOU INVITED ME,
KEENYAH!
>> I KNOW. I WAS--
I WENT THROUGH IT IN MY HEAD.
I SAID, I MEAN,
I COULD'VE PICKED NAIMA--
NO, SHE'S NEVER PICKED ME.
NEXT ON THE LIST PROBABLY
WOULD'VE BEEN KAHLEN.
>> OVER CHRISTINA?
>> CHRISTINA WOULD'VE BEEN,
LIKE, ALL STRAIGHT CONNECTS,
PROBABLY NO CONVERSATION
WITH ME.
IT'S A DINNER PARTY
WITH INDUSTRY PEOPLE,
AND I WANT TO HAVE FUN,
BUT STILL TRY
TO GET MORE CONNECTIONS.
♪♪♪
>> CAN I MAKE A TOAST?
TO MY FAVORITE GIRLS
IN THIS COMPETITION.
NAIMA, YOU HAVE GIVEN ME
SO MUCH STRENGTH,
AND I FEEL LIKE
I'M MOST COMFORTABLE TO YOU.
TO CHRISTINA, EVEN IF THEY SAY
YOU'RE COLD AND HEARTLESS,
YOU'RE THE MOST
AFFECTIONATE PERSON
I'VE SEEN HERE.
>> WE'VE HAD
SOME AMAZING GIRLS GO.
AND THERE'S STILL TO BE
SOME MORE AMAZING GIRLS GO,
AND WE DON'T KNOW WHO
IS GONNA BE STANDING.
>> CHEERS.
>> CHEERS TO THAT.
♪♪♪
>> THANK YOU.
>> WE'RE WALKING UP
THIS BEAUTIFUL WALKWAY
TO THIS HOUSE,
AND WE'RE THINKING
IT'S JUST GONNA BE CRAIG AND,
LIKE, FIVE OTHER
INDUSTRY PEOPLE.
>> HELLO.
KEENYAH, BRITTANY.
>> HELLO! HOW ARE YOU?
>> AND WE GET UP THERE.
AND WE'RE LIKE, "WHOA, THIS IS
A MAJOR INDUSTRY PARTY."
AND I GET REALLY,
REALLY EXCITED, BECAUSE FOR ME
TO BE ABLE TO COME AND GET
ALL THESE
SOUTH AFRICAN, LIKE, CONNECTIONS
IS SO AMAZING.
>> CHEERS, EVERYONE.
>> CHEERS. CHEERS.
THAT'S WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR.
>> WE'RE EATING
AND HAVING CONVERSATIONS--
BRITTANY'S VOICE IS SO CARRYING.
SHE'S BASICALLY TALKING
TO EVERYONE IN THE TABLE,
AND SHE'S BUSTING
ALL THESE JOKES, AND, YOU KNOW,
IT'S LIKE, "HELLO,
I WON THE CHALLENGE!"
>> I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
REALLY CRAZY,
AND I PUT ON A SHOW
FOR EVERYONE.
I KNOW I'M ANNOYING.
>> I DO REGRET PICKING BRITTANY
TO COME WITH ME BECAUSE
SHE'S THE TYPE OF PERSON WHO,
WHEN IT COMES TO THE SPOTLIGHT,
SHE'S ALWAYS IN IT,
SO IT JUST REALLY PISSED ME OFF.
>> OH, YES.
♪♪♪
>> I END UP WINNING
THE CHALLENGE.
AND SO I GET TO GO OFF
TO A PARTY WITH CRAIG PORT
AT HIS HOUSE.
>> WE DIDN'T ANNOY
YOU GUYS TOO MUCH?
WE DIDN'T ANNOY YOU?
>> OH, BUT LOOK HOW YOU
RELAXED WITH US.
>> I LOVE IT.
>> BRITTANY'S PERSONALITY
IS SO GREAT AND OUTGOING
THAT I FEEL LIKE, "HELLO,
I'M IN THE BACKGROUND."
>> I THINK WE HAD A LOT OF FUN.
>> I HAD A GREAT TIME TONIGHT.
AND I REALLY HAD
THE BEST TIME I'VE HAD
IN THIS WHOLE
ENTIRE COMPETITION.
>> BYE, BRITTANY.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> OKAY.
>> THAT WAS FUN.
WE HAD A REALLY GOOD TIME.
I HAD A GREAT TIME.
>> THEY WERE LIKE,
YOU WERE KINDA QUIET
IN COMPARISON TO BRITTANY."
I WAS LIKE, "YEAH."
>> TYRA MAIL.
>> "GET READY TO KLOOF."
CAPITAL "K." KLOOF.
"BE READY AT 6 A.M."
>> OH, OKAY, LET'S--
>> OH, MY TOE, BRITTANY!
♪♪♪
>> HELLO, GUYS.
GOOD MORNING, GUYS.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> HOW YOU DOIN'?
NICE AND EARLY, HUH?
>> YEAH.
>> WHAT WE'RE DOING TODAY IS
WHAT THEY CALL HERE KLOOFING.
KLOOFING IS GOING THROUGH
WATER, ROCKS UPSTREAM
THROUGH A CANYON
TO THE LOCATION.
SO THIS IS
YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER TODAY.
>> HELLO, GIRLS.
>> ANTON ROBERT.
>> HI.
>> HI. AAH!
>> GET INTO A WET SUIT.
YOU DON'T LOOK
SO EXCITED, BRITTANY.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> I JUST WOKE UP.
>> YOU GET IN THAT WATER,
YOU'RE GONNA BE WIDE AWAKE.
>> YEAH, RIGHT.
>> SO LET'S GET THESE WET SUITS
ON AND LET'S GET GOING.
>> WHAT IS THAT?
BIRD POOP.
GIVE ME THE SUIT CAMOUFLAGED IN
GREAT!
>> KEENYAH--SHE'S LIKE,
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS
HAS TO DO WITH MODELING."
AND I'M LIKE, "WELL, YEAH,
SOMETIMES IF YOU HAVE TO GET
TO A LOCATION
WHERE YOU CAN'T DRIVE TO,
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO GET THERE
SOME KIND OF A WAY."
>> WHAT KIND OF ANIMAL IS THAT?
>> YEAH, MY TOES ARE NUMB!
>> OKAY.
>> WOW.
>> AAH!
>> I'M HAVING A HARD TIME
KLOOFING BECAUSE I CAN'T SEE
THE BOTTOM OF THE STREAM,
SO I NEVER KNOW
WHERE I'M STEPPING.
OHH!
AHH! HA HA HA.
>> OH, WHAT IS THIS--
SOMETHING WAS BUBBLING.
>> DID YOU FART?
>> NO.
>> KLOOFING--IT WAS AN
EXPERIENCE.
DEFINITELY AN EXPERIENCE.
>> HEY.
WHAT TOOK YOU GUYS SO LONG?
>> JAY! JAY!
>> NOW I KNOW YOU HAVE HIKED
THIS LONG WAY, YOU FEEL TIRED,
YOU DON'T LOOK SO GOOD,
BUT YOUR JOB
WITH THIS PHOTO SHOOT
IS TO LOOK GORGEOUS AND SERENE
EVEN AFTER KLOOFING.
AND YOUR WARDROBE TODAY
IS ACTUALLY GOING TO BE
THE ENVIRONMENT.
YOU'RE GONNA PULL
LEAVES, BRANCHES, TWINE,
AND YOU'RE GONNA MAKE
YOUR WARDROBE.
ALL RIGHT? SO YOU PSYCHED?
>> YES.
>> YOU'RE A BEAUTIFUL GIRL,
BUT YOU'RE A BIG MESS.
>> A BIG MESS.
>> ARE YOU HELPING US
WITH THE STYLE
OR IT'S ALL ON US?
>> NO, NO. IT'S ALL ON YOU,
BABY.
>> SO I HAVE TO GO FIND
AN OUTFIT MADE OUT OF GRASS,
LEAVES, WHATEVER
THAT IS AROUND US.
MY PICTURE HAS TO BE BEAUTIFUL
AS WELL AS WHAT I'M WEARING.
SO FOR ME TO HAVE TO PICK IT
IS, LIKE, VERY SCARY.
>> YOU NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW
IT'S GONNA LOOK ON YOUR BODY.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO LOOK LIKE?
WHAT YOU WANT TO ACCENTUATE.
THIS IS A COMPETITION.
>> I NEED SOMETHING THAT'S--
NONE OF THE OTHER GIRLS
ARE GONNA TRY TO ROCK.
>> OH, THAT IS CUTE.
NOW YOU'RE THINKIN' SMART.
>> I'M GETTING THEM ALL
SO NO ONE ELSE CAN GET THEM.
>> LET'S THINK ABOUT THIS LOOK.
>> SOMETHING EDGY IS GONNA--
>> EDGY TO GO WITH YOUR HAIR.
>> I LIKE THE IDEA OF JUST,
LIKE, BLENDING IN
BECAUSE I'M PART OF THE EARTH,
AND THIS EARTH IS PART OF ME.
>> CAN I USE THE MUD?
>> YOU CAN USE ANYTHING.
>> MUD IT IS.
SO I'M CALLING MUD.
>> I DON'T REALLY THINK
GREEN'S MY COLOR.
I WENT WITH STICKS,
DEAD STICKS.
BECAUSE I'M GONNA GO
FOR MORE BROWN INSTEAD OF GREEN
SO THAT WAY, I STAND OUT.
>> SO I HAVE TO BE AWARE THAT,
YOU KNOW,
I WANT TO COVER MY STOMACH
SO I GET THE STRAW TYPE STUFF,
GLUE IT ALL ACROSS MY STOMACH.
SO YOU CAN SEE
A LITTLE BIT OF IT,
BUT IT'S STILL VERY FLATTERING.
>> OKAY, LET'S GO.
♪♪♪
>> SO NOW, KEENYAH, YOU GOTTA
JUST MAKE THIS LOOK
REALLY SERENE, BEAUTIFUL.
ALL RIGHT?
>> SO IT'S BEEN BROUGHT
TO MY ATTENTION THAT I'VE PUT ON
A FEW POUNDS AND, YOU KNOW,
I NEED TO REALLY BEWARE
OF HOW MY BODY IS LOOKING.
>> SIT ON THE ROCK THERE.
>> WHEN YOU SIT ON A ROCK--
YOU SHOULD TALK TO TYRA
ABOUT THIS.
SHE'S AMAZING AT THIS.
YOU ALMOST HAVE TO NOT SIT DOWN,
OTHERWISE IT MAKES YOU
LOOK POUCHY HERE,
AND YOU HAVE TO HOLD
YOUR STOMACH IN, TOO.
YOU'VE GOTTA KIND OF
HOLD IN, LEAN BACK,
BUT THEN LOOK BEAUTIFUL.
SHE'S REALLY GAINING
A LITTLE WEIGHT.
YOU CAN SEE THAT, NO?
>> YEAH.
>> SHE SHOULD BE CAREFUL
OF THAT.
JUST TRY AND PULL IT IN
A LITTLE MORE.
PRETTY. YES.
THERE YOU GO.
>> KEENYAH USUALLY MOVES
VERY WELL,
BUT SHE FELT VERY AWKWARD.
I JUST EXPECTED
SO MUCH MORE FROM HER.
I LOVE THIS MUD. IT'S--
WAS THAT YOUR IDEA?
>> YEAH.
I LIKE THE IDEA
OF JUST, LIKE, BLENDING IN
WITH THE ENVIRONMENT.
SO THAT WAS MY MOTIF.
>> FACE THAT WAY.
THAT'S QUITE NICE.
YOU LOOK GOOD IN PROFILE.
I FELT LIKE NAIMA WAS STILL
POSING IN FRONT OF A CAMERA
AS OPPOSED TO ME WITNESSING
THIS SPECIAL MOMENT
IN FRONT OF A WATERFALL.
>> I SEE A BIG PILE OF MUD
RIGHT IN FRONT OF ME,
AND IT'S NASTY.
WELL, THERE'S MY OUTFIT
RIGHT THERE.
SO I JUST GO STRAIGHT DOWN
IN THE MUD AND LAY IN IT
AND FLOP AROUND LIKE A HIPPO.
>> AND I'M SO NOT GONNA HELP YOU
'CAUSE YOU'RE ICKY.
JUST BE CAREFUL.
>> NOT TOO SEXY. INTIMATE.
>> OKAY, RELAX YOUR FACE. RELAX.
>> THINK OF YOURSELF AS, LIKE,
THIS MYTHICAL NYMPH
IN THE JUNGLE.
OH, THAT'S PRETTY.
SOFTEN IT A BIT.
BRITTANY DID A GREAT JOB.
SHE REALLY CHANGED UP
HER BODY LANGUAGE A LOT.
THERE WERE A LOT OF GREAT POSES,
AND YOU NEVER ONCE GOT TOO SEXY.
>> HAVING TO STYLE MYSELF
IS A BAD THING FOR ME
BECAUSE I'VE BECOME SO RELIANT
ON THE TEAM THAT GETS US
PREPARED FOR THE PHOTO SHOOT.
>> AND WHEN YOU ARE UP THERE,
JUST GO ALL THE WAY.
>> THERE WE GO.
>> I KNOW YOU'VE GOT
AMAZING BODY LANGUAGE,
SO I WANT YOU TO DO THAT HERE.
HEY, DO YOU FEEL SEXY TODAY?
I DON'T BELIEVE YOU.
>> WHAT I'M STRUGGLING WITH
IS MY SENSUAL SIDE.
WHEN I TRY TO BE SEXY, I JUST
KINDA LOOK LIKE A CORNBALL.
>> LOOK AT THAT.
LIKE, WHAT IS THAT?
SHE JUST DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT SEXY OR BEAUTIFUL IS,
AND IT'S REALLY KILLING
MY IMPRESSION OF HER.
I ALWAYS THOUGHT
SHE WAS ONE OF BETTER POSERS.
AND IT'S LIKE SHE'S GETTING
WEAKER.
>> IF YOU HAD TO SELL THIS LOOK,
WHAT WOULD YOU CALL IT?
>> RUSTIC.
>> MY LOOK TODAY--
IT'S A LOT MORE SENSUAL
THAN I THINK I'VE EVER BEEN.
AND, UM, A LOT LESS CLOTHES
THAN I'VE EVER HAD.
>> I WANT YOU TO JUST TAKE IN
THE ENVIRONMENT.
LOOK HOW BEAUTIFUL IT IS.
YOU JUST GET COMFORTABLE
AND FIND SOMETHING
THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
ELBOW. COME DOWN ON THE ELBOW.
THAT'S BEAUTIFUL. HOLD IT.
>> HEY, CHRISTINA,
SIT ON THE EDGE OF THE ROCK
WITH YOUR LEGS OVER.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT'S CUTE.
I LIKE THAT.
OH, YEAH, OR EVEN THAT.
>> I HAVE BEEN, YOU KNOW, TRYING
TO LOSE THE VERY STERN LOOK
AND COME ACROSS MORE WARM
AND MORE SENSUAL AND STUFF.
>> NO, I LIKE IT.
CHRISTINA WAS
A LITTLE TECHNICAL
WITH HER POSES TODAY.
BUT THERE WAS SUCH A SENSITIVITY
IN HER FACE.
>> I FEEL LIKE I ACCOMPLISHED,
YOU KNOW, SOMETHING THAT
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO WORK AT.
HOPEFULLY IT PAID OFF,
AND WE'LL SEE
WHAT GOES FROM THERE.
>> LET'S GO!
♪♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL.
WHO WOULDA KNOWN?
>> "TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET WITH
THE JUDGES.
ONLY FOUR OF YOU WILL CONTINUE
IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
>> OHH.
NO MATTER WHO LEAVES NOW,
IT'S SOMEONE THAT
I REALLY LIKE AS A FRIEND.
>> HONEST TO GOD, I DO NOT KNOW
WHO'S GOING HOME.
I'M GONNA HAVE TO GO IN THERE
AND GIVE 100% OF MY HEART
SO THAT THEY SEE THAT, YOU KNOW,
I'M NOT
JUST THIS TOUGH EXTERIOR.
>> I'M SO WIDE.
>> NO, YOU'RE NOT.
THAT'S WHY IT LOOKS GOOD ON YOU.
>> SO NOW, GOING INTO PANEL
IS REALLY UP IN THE AIR.
IT REALLY DEPENDS ON
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE
IN FRONT OF THE PANEL.
>> I'M ALWAYS EXCITED TO SEE HOW
MY PHOTOS ARE GONNA COME OUT.
YEAH, WE MAY HAVE HAD
A GREAT TIME
WITH THE PHOTOGRAPHER,
BUT ULTIMATELY,
WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO IT,
WE HAVE TO IMPRESS
THOSE FIVE JUDGES.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T FEEL THAT I PERFORMED
MY BEST FOR THIS PHOTO SHOOT.
I AM REALLY NERVOUS
BECAUSE THERE IS A CHANCE OF ME
GOING HOME
BECAUSE OF MY PHOTO SHOOT.
I DIDN'T FEEL THAT IT WENT SO
WELL.
AND IT'S REALLY SCARY.
>> WE'LL SEE TOMORROW.
♪♪♪
>> WELCOME, LADIES.
NOW IT'S TIME TO MAKE
OUR TENTH CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING US ONE STEP
CLOSER
TOWARDS DETERMINING
WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
NOW YOU GUYS KNOW WE HAVE
SOME FABULOUS PRIZES,
THE FIRST BEING A CONTRACT
FROM TOP INTERNATIONAL
MODEL MANAGEMENT COMPANY
FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE,
WHICH WILL BE SHOT
BY WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
YOU KNOW OUR JUDGES.
THE FIRST--
MISS JANICE DICKINSON.
JANICE IS ONE OF THE WORLD'S
FIRST SUPER MODELS.
MR. NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
NOLE MARIN,
PROMINENT FASHION EDITOR
AND STYLIST.
AND WE'RE VERY LUCKY TO HAVE
OUR GUEST JUDGE TODAY--
PAOLA DEVITO.
SHE IS THE C.E.O.
OF THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF MODELING AGENCIES.
>> IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
>> HI.
>> THIS WEEK, THE MODELS
DID SOMETHING CALLED KLOOFING.
>> KLOOFING?
>> IT'S LIKE GOING ON A TREK,
AND THEY HAD TO FIND
THEIR OWN WARDROBE IN NATURE.
I GOT THE IDEA
BECAUSE I HAD TO KLOOF
TO A LOCATION IN SOUTH AMERICA
WHERE I HAD TO MAKE
MY OWN WARDROBE
FOR A SWIMSUIT CALENDAR.
NOW WE'RE GONNA TAKE A LOOK
AT YOU GIRL'S PHOTOS,
BUT WE ARE GOING TO BE DOING IT
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY.
OVER THE PAST TEN WEEKS,
YOU GUYS,
YOU HAVE BEEN TAUGHT
A LOT ABOUT WHAT IT TAKES
TO BE A TOP MODEL.
NOW THIS WEEK, WE'RE GOING TO
TURN THE TABLES ON YOU.
YOU ALL ARE SO USED TO
BEING JUDGED BY US.
NOW YOU'RE GOING TO JUDGE
EACH OTHER.
IT'S ABOUT BEING HONEST
BECAUSE WE'RE REALLY TESTING
YOUR KNOWLEDGE OF THE BUSINESS.
SO FIRST IS BRITTANY.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
OKAY, KEENYAH, GO FIRST.
>> IT LOOKS A LITTLE BIT STIFF,
BASED ON, UH, JUST THE POSTURE
AGAINST THE ROCK.
>> WOW.
I HAVE TO DISAGREE WITH YOU.
I THINK THAT
HER STANCE EMPHASIZES
HOW LONG SHE IS
AND ALSO ADDS
TO THE LINE OF THE WATERFALL.
>> I LOVE THE FACE.
I THINK IT'S VERY STRONG.
SHE SHOWS A LOT
OF EMOTION THROUGH THE EYES.
>> AS FAR AS
THE MUD ON THE NECK,
I DO THINK
IT MAKES HER LOOK THICKER.
>> ALL RIGHT, BRITTANY. THANKS.
KAHLEN. HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> THE FACE IS LIKE, "WHO, ME?"
UM, KIND OF CONFUSED, DAZED.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE, YOU KNOW,
LIKE, "WHAT?"
LIKE "ARE YOU TAKING A PICTURE?"
>> YES, SHE DOES LOOK SURPRISED,
BUT THAT ADDS TO HER BEING
A PART OF THE SURROUNDING.
>> I THINK IT'S A REALLY GOOD
SHOT.
>> THANKS, KAHLEN.
NEXT IS CHRISTINA.
>> I THINK THAT SHOULDER
IS HUNCHED OVER,
A LITTLE HUNCHBACK.
A LITTLE BIT...
>> I THINK THE FACE IS GREAT.
I THINK
WITH HER LIPS OPEN LIKE THAT,
IT MAKES THEM LOOK NOT AS THIN.
>> I CAN SEE THAT SHE'S TRYING
TO EXPLORE SOMETHING NEW HERE.
>> I LOVE IT. I REALLY...
I DON'T KNOW,
IT'S SOMETHING ABOUT IT
THAT CAPTURES ME.
>> THANKS, CHRISTINA.
>> KEENYAH, HERE IS
YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> I DON'T LIKE THIS FACE.
IT LOOKS LIKE SHE'S
SMELLING SOMETHING ROTTEN.
>> I DON'T FEEL HER EYES HAVE
ENOUGH EMOTION IN THEM.
>> I DON'T LIKE THE LEFT LEG.
SHE LOOKS LIKE SHE'S AMPUTATED.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I'M NOT REALLY...
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
MAYBE IF SHE--THE LIPS?
I CAN'T PINPOINT IT.
YEAH. I'M DONE.
>> LAST IS NAIMA.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> I LOVE THE POSITIONING
OF HER BODY,
BUT I DON'T FEEL LIKE THERE'S
ENOUGH EMOTION IN THE EYES.
>> THE BACK OF THE NECK
LOOKS A LITTLE STIFF.
>> HER LEFT LEG,
I CAN'T SEE HER FOOT.
>> I DON'T SEE ENVIRONMENT.
I SEE MAYBE DIRTY
IN HER UNDERWEAR.
JUST DIRTY.
>> OVERALL, I THINK
IT'S A REALLY GOOD SHOT.
>> THE NEXT THING
WE ARE GOING TO JUDGE
ARE YOUR OPINIONS
ABOUT WHO YOU THINK HAS
THE MOST TOP MODEL POTENTIAL,
WHO YOU THINK HAS
THE LEAST TOP MODEL POTENTIAL.
KEENYAH?
>> OKAY, UM, IT'S IN BETWEEN
BRITTANY AND KAHLEN THAT HAS
THE MOST POTENTIAL.
THE PERSON WHO I THINK MAY HAVE
THE LEAST POTENTIAL IN THIS...
I WOULD PROBABLY
HAVE TO SAY NAIMA.
THAT'S BECAUSE THERE'S A SHELL
AROUND HER SOMETIMES.
>> CHRISTINA.
>> I WOULD SAY KAHLEN--
TOP MODEL.
WHEN SHE GETS IN THOSE PICTURES,
SHE LOOKS LIKE
THIS FIERCE SUPER MODEL.
UM, THIS IS HARD. WOW.
UM, I WOULD SAY BRITTANY
AS THE LEAST.
I FEEL LIKE
SHE'S MORE PINPOINTED
TOWARDS ONE CERTAIN LOOK.
>> NEXT IS NAIMA.
>> MOST TOP MODEL POTENTIAL,
I WOULD HAVE TO SAY KAHLEN.
ALL AROUND, SHE'S STRONG.
LEAST TOP MODEL POTENTIAL...
THAT'S HARD.
THESE GIRLS...
I WOULD HAVE TO SAY CHRISTINA.
SHE PHOTOGRAPHS WELL,
BUT FOR ME, SHE'S BLAND.
>> NEXT IS BRITTANY.
>> FIRST OF ALL,
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT
I THINK THAT I AM GONNA BE
THE NEXT TOP MODEL.
AND I'M JUST...
IF I HAVE TO PICK ONE GIRL
THAT I THINK IS BETTER
THAN ALL OF THE REST,
I WOULD GO AHEAD
AND PICK KEENYAH.
I GO BY PERSONALITY.
I LOVE A GIRL
THAT MAKES ME LAUGH.
UM, THE LEAST STRONGEST,
I WOULD SAY CHRISTINA.
I JUST HAVEN'T, IN THIS TIME,
REALLY KNOWN WHO SHE IS.
>> KAHLEN.
>> KEENYAH IS THE STRONGEST.
I'VE SEEN HER PHOTO SHOOTS,
AND WHEN SHE IS UP THERE,
SHE IS SO CONFIDENT IN HERSELF
AND SHE IS SO GRACEFUL.
WHEN IT COMES TO
LEAST POTENTIAL...
ONCE AGAIN,
I'M GONNA HAVE AGREE WITH SOME
OF THE GIRLS
AND SAY IT IS CHRISTINA.
SHE CAN, YOU KNOW, SELL
THE MORE EXPENSIVE DESIGNS
AND STUFF LIKE THAT,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE THROWN
INTO THAT RIGHT OFF OF THE BAT.
>> I WANNA THANK
ALL OF YOU GUYS
FOR YOUR HONESTY.
YOU KNOW, THAT TAKES A LOT OF
COURAGE,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
IT IS WHAT YOU NEED TO GET
TO THE NEXT LEVEL
BECAUSE WHEN YOU GET
INTO THE MODELING WORLD
OUT THERE WITH THE SHARKS,
YOU NEED TO KNOW
YOUR COMPETITION.
YOU NEED TO KNOW THEIR STRENGTHS
AND YOUR WEAKNESSES.
NOW WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS WE'RE GONNA EVALUATE YOU
ONE BY ONE.
FIRST IS KEENYAH.
I THINK YOU HAVE
A LITTLE LEVEL OF CATTINESS.
I FELT LIKE
YOU GAVE YOUR CRITIQUE
ALMOST AS IF YOU THINK
YOU'RE THE BEST.
AND I WAS SURPRISED THAT
WHEN WE ASKED WHO HAD
THE MOST TOP MODEL POTENTIAL,
YOU DIDN'T SAY YOURSELF.
NOT ONE OF YOU SAID YOURSELF.
YOU KIND OF SAID IT
FOR A SECOND BRITTANY,
AND THEN BACKED RIGHT OUT OF IT.
I NEEDED TO SEE SOMEONE
REALLY SAY THAT
AND REALLY BELIEVE THAT.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW
WE HAD THAT OPTION.
>> ANYTHING'S POSSIBLE.
>> SO NOW WE'RE GONNA SEE
YOUR BEST SHOT
FROM OUR VIEWPOINT.
>> BODY POSITION, WEAK,
BUT YOUR FACE
IS ABSOLUTELY STUNNING.
>> YOUR FACE IS GORGEOUS,
BUT I HATE TO SAY IT,
IT DOES NOT SHOW FASHION.
IT'S JUST A BEAUTIFUL YOUNG
LADY,
YOU KNOW, ON A PICNIC
WITH HER BOYFRIEND.
>> CHRISTINA.
>> I THINK YOUR CRITIQUE
ON EVERYONE--
YOU'RE SO BEAUTIFUL,
BUT YOU'RE SLIGHTLY BORING
WITH YOUR DELIVERY.
>> LIKE A ROBOT.
>> IT WAS JUST LIKE A ROBOT.
>> BUT A BEAUTIFUL ROBOT.
>> IF YOU WALKED IN MY DOORS,
I DON'T KNOW HOW I'D SELL YOU,
BECAUSE I'M NOT FEELING ANYTHING
FROM YOU.
>> I DON'T KNOW...
WHERE CONFIDENCE MEETS COLD.
>> YOU'VE GOT IT IN YOU.
YOU'RE A GORGEOUS GIRL.
YOU JUST HAVE TO BE CAREFUL.
>> HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> THE POSE SUCKS.
>> YOU PULLED
YOUR LEG TO YOURSELF,
LOST YOU ANKLE.
>> I DISAGREE WITH THEM.
YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT ABOUT A
CROPPED ANKLE TO ME.
IT'S NOT ABOUT GOOD POSTURE.
IN FACT, THERE WAS AN ARTICLE
IN THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
ABOUT MODELS SLOUCHING,
HOW THAT IS THE NEW POSTURE
FOR THE FASHION INDUSTRY.
THAT IT'S ALL ABOUT THE HUNCH.
NAIMA.
>> YOU ARE SUCH A GORGEOUS GIRL,
BUT WHEN YOU WALK
INTO THIS ROOM,
YOU'RE LIKE AN EGG,
AND I JUST WANT TO TAKE YOU
AND CRACK YOU OPEN.
>> I HAVE BLOCKED
A LOT OF MYSELF
BECAUSE I HAVE BEEN
THAT ANGRY GIRL WHO I WAS
FOR A LONG TIME.
AND I DON'T LIKE TO REVISIT
THAT.
>> THAT SOFT, NICE,
SWEET VOICE--IT'S GONE.
NOW YOU'RE REAL.
NOW I'M GETTING A SENSE OF WHO
YOU ARE.
>> YOUR CRITIQUES WERE
BRILLIANT.
>> I AGREE.
>> QUITE FRANKLY,
YOU TOOK THE WORDS
OUT OF MY MOUTH.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO YOU HAD A PHOTO
SHOOT.
>> THE FACE IS COMPLETELY DEAD,
AS IF THEY DRAINED EVERY OUNCE
OF BLOOD OUT OF YOU.
>> MOST OF THE PHOTOS
THAT WERE AMAZING
WERE OF YOU 3/4 OR PROFILE,
AND WE FEEL LIKE
MOST OF YOUR SELECTS HAVE BEEN
3/4 OR PROFILE.
TO BE A TOP MODEL,
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO BE
PHOTOGRAPHED FROM THE FRONT.
AND FOR SOME REASON,
FROM THE FRONT, YOU LOSE IT.
KAHLEN.
>> KAHLEN, I THOUGHT
YOUR ACCURACY ON THE CRITIQUES
WAS WELL THOUGHT OUT.
>> I WAS VERY IMPRESSED.
I SAW EVERY SINGLE THING
THAT YOU LEARNED HERE.
>> THERE'S SOMETHING
ABOUT HER FACE.
YOU'RE ANGELIC.
>> THIS IS A GOOD SHOT,
BUT THERE WEREN'T MANY.
USUALLY YOU HAVE A LOT
OF GOOD PHOTOS TO CHOOSE FROM.
BUT THIS TIME IT LOOKED LIKE
IT WAS YOUR VERY FIRST
PHOTO SHOOT AND THAT
YOU LUCKED UPON GOOD ONES.
>> PLEASE DON'T GET TOO
COMPLACENT.
'CAUSE I'VE SEEN IT BEFORE,
A MILLION TIMES.
>> BRITTANY.
>> WHEN YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE GIRLS,
I REALLY FELT THAT
YOU'RE NOT IN A COMPETITION,
YOU'RE IN HIGH SCHOOL.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE A GIRL
OFF THE FARM.
LIKE, "IT LOOKS GOOD TO BE ME.
I LIKE IT. I DON'T KNOW.
IT LOOKS GOOD."
AND I WAS LIKE,
"HAVEN'T YOU LEARNED ANYTHING?"
>> HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> WOW. YOU LOOK HOT.
>> IT'S AMAZING.
>> GUYS WOULD STICK THIS
UP ON THEIR WALLS
IN A HEARTBEAT.
>> WOMEN WILL WANT TO BE THAT,
AND GUYS WILL WANT
TO BE WITH IT.
>> MM-HMM. THIS IS A SEX BOMB
SHOT.
>> YOU'RE JUST A BIG, OLD
HORNY... JUDGE.
♪♪♪
>> NAIMA.
>> NAIMA IN THIS PHOTO
IS ABSOLUTELY HORRENDOUS.
IT'S HORRIFIC.
>> BUT SHE SHOWED
A DIFFERENT SIDE OF HERSELF.
I'M FALLING IN LOVE
WITH NAIMA ALL OVER AGAIN.
>> CHRISTINA.
>> SHE DEFINITELY NEEDS TO
PUMP UP THE LIP WITH SOMETHING,
LIP GLOSS OR COLLAGEN.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT
CHRISTINA NEEDS SURGERY.
SHE'S A BEAUTIFUL GIRL
IN SO MANY WAYS.
>> THE PROBLEM IS
SHE'S TOO ICY, SHE'S TOO COLD.
>> KAHLEN.
>> KAHLEN IN THIS SHOT
IS ETHEREAL
AND A LITTLE BIT LOLITA.
>> SHE COMPLETELY
STUNNED ME TONIGHT
WITH HER DEEP INSIGHT TO THE
BUSINESS.
>> KEENYAH.
>> I THINK KEENYAH'S
A BEAUTIFUL WOMAN.
I THINK SHE'S GOT
TREMENDOUS CONFIDENCE.
>> BUT IN THIS PHOTO,
I DON'T SEE A MODEL
AND THE BODY
DEFINITELY NEEDS WORK.
>> BRITTANY.
>> BRITTANY LOOKS DROP-DEAD
GORGEOUS IN THIS PICTURE.
BUT STILL, THAT'S NOT LEARNING,
THAT'S NOT PROGRESSING.
>> SHE'S GOT SOUL AND PASSION.
I LIKE HER.
>> I'M SORRY, JANICE,
BUT MISS BRITTANY LOOKS LIKE
YOUR LITTLE SISTER, AND THAT'S
WHY YOU FEELIN' HER,
BECAUSE YOU KNOW
YOU SEE YOURSELF.
DON'T LIE.
>> JANICE, YOUR FIRST FACE, YES.
>> DON'T GET ME GOING, SHORT,
FAT, SQUATTY, BALD BLIND BOY.
>> DON'T WORRY,
MY PLASTIC SURGERY VICTIM
FREAK OF NATURE.
>> THIS IS WHAT I WAS
WAITING FOR THE WHOLE NIGHT.
♪♪♪
>> FROM WEEK TO WEEK,
YOU COME IN HERE
AND WE EVALUATE YOU.
BUT TONIGHT,
THE TABLES WERE TURNED AND YOU
HAD TO LOOK AT THE WOMAN
TO YOUR LEFT AND LOOK AT
THE WOMAN TO YOUR RIGHT AND
EVALUATE HER.
AND YOU ALL HELPED US
MAKE THIS DECISION TODAY.
FIVE BEAUTIFUL WOMEN
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE
FOUR PHOTOS IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE FOUR PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE GIRLS THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME THAT I'M GOING TO
CALL...
NAIMA.
I'M PROUD OF YOU BECAUSE
FOR THE FIRST TIME,
THESE PEOPLE BEHIND ME
SAW THE TRUE YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> KEENYAH.
KEENYAH, YOU WERE
SKATING ON THIN ICE.
SAME CRITIQUE AS BEFORE,
TOO SAFE, TOO SAFE.
WE NEED TO SEE A MODEL
IN YOUR PICTURES,
NOT JUST A PRETTY GIRL.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
KAHLEN.
KAHLEN, THE ONE THAT
EVERYONE THINKS SHE IS SO MEEK,
BUT SHE'S GOT
AN OPINION AND A HALF.
YOU KNOW THIS FASHION INDUSTRY
A LOT BETTER THAN
A LOT OF WORKING MODELS TODAY.
BUT THIS SHOOT
WAS YOUR WORST YET.
YOU DON'T WANT SHOTS
THAT ARE LUCK LIKE THIS ONE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> WILL BRITTANY AND CHRISTINA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WILL ONLY CALL ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE HOTEL,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND GO HOME.
THE INTERESTING THING
WITH YOU TWO IS THAT
YOU'RE NOT STANDING BEFORE ME
BECAUSE YOU TAKE BAD PICTURES.
YOU TWO
BOTH TAKE LOVELY PICTURES.
ONE OF YOU PROBABLY HAS
THE HEART AND SOUL OF AN ANGEL.
I KNOW THERE'S SOMEONE IN THERE
THAT IS JUST SOFT AND WARM.
BUT WHAT THE JUDGES SEE
FROM WEEK TO WEEK
IS SOMEONE THAT'S COLD
AND THAT'S ICY.
ONE OF YOU IS FULL OF LIFE,
A CHARACTER,
BUT THERE'S A TIME FOR PLAY
AND A TIME FOR WORK.
WE DON'T SEE PROGRESS.
THE CHALLENGE TODAY
MADE US ALL SAY,
"WHAT HAS SHE LEARNED?"
>> BRITTANY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> NO, I'M NOT THIS COLD, LIKE,
RESERVED PERSON EXCEPT FOR WHEN
I GOT IN PANEL.
I FELT LIKE I PUT UP THIS WALL,
I JUST WISH I WOULD HAVE BEEN
ABLE
TO SHOW THEM
THE WARMER SIDE OF ME.
>> I THINK IT WAS A REALLY BIG
LESSON LEARNED.
IT'S MY FAULT,
BUT IT'S SOMETHING
I HAVE TO LEARN FROM
AND JUST GROW...
AND THEN GO FROM THERE.
>> COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
WITH ONLY 4 GIRLS LEFT,
NERVES CRACK...
>> IS THIS SOME KIND OF SMALL
ATTACK ON ME?
>> TEMPERS FLARE...
>> WELL, I DON'T TO HEAR IT.
>> I KNOW.
>> AND FRIENDSHIPS
ARE TORN APART.
>> IF YOU WANT TO THINK THAT I'M
SELFISH, YOU GO AHEAD
AND THINK THAT I'M SELFISH.
>> SHUT UP!